dragons cast a large shadow over the
mythologies of the world
few legendary monsters can compare to
these gigantic beasts
but what if dragons cast a slightly
smaller shadow what if some dragons
weren't huge monsters but strange and
secretive creatures evolved to live
hidden lives in the shadows and margins
of the world the amazing artist and
writer andy frazier imagines a world
where dragons are all around us from the
highest mountains to the deepest forest
concentrated primarily in the author's
homeland of wales these smaller dragons
or micro dragons as i call them make up
for their reduced size with their
incredible diversity and ingenious
survival strategies the author has
released many field guides on these tiny
wonders that explore their evolution
anatomy behavior and habitats in great
detail which you can find linked below
so for this entry into the archive i'll
assume the role of naturalist and
observe some of these creatures out in
the field
now let's head off into the welsh
countryside and discover the secret
biology of micro dragons
at the start of the expedition the first
place i look for micro dragons is on the
low branches of trees here a
draconotophthalmus suns themselves in
the morning light while this stunning
specimen can fly like a bird internally
they have several key distinctions that
make their anatomy unique
if we examined their skeleton we'd find
dragon bones are denser than a birds
making them better suited to life on the
ground where most dragon species spend
part of their time
in many species the neural spines along
the backbone are also greatly enlarged
forming obvious spikes
in the case of
draconotophthalmus these long spikes can
be raised and lowered as a threat
display for the notoph thalamus survives
by trying to appear as dangerous and
intimidating as possible making loud
vocalizations and threatening postures
as i pass by from an evolutionary
perspective this approach has been
remarkably successful for a dragon that
in reality is a very timid herbivore
venturing deeper into the woodland i
find that no two dragons have the same
survival strategy
splashing along the surface of a stream
is a brightly colored emerald scythe
unlike the notoph thalamus this more
basal species is covered in fine wind
resistant fibers the prehistoric
appearance of the emerald scythe sheds
light into the origins of micro dragons
the distant ancestor of welsh dragons
the dimorphodon macronyx branched off
from pterosaurs some 190 million years
ago surviving the mass extinction that
wiped out their more famous cousins
thanks to their diminutive size and more
adaptable nature today modern dragons
have branched off into ever more
specialized subspecies with the emerald
scythe the scavenger of fallen seeds and
berries they also have a fondness for
playing among the spray of rivers
although there appears to be no
practical benefit for this and is
probably done just for fun
near a patch of wildflowers a barely
audible buzzing draws me closer
hovering near a carefully chosen flower
is the fascinating draco sep diana on
delicate green and red wings draco
septiana darts between flowers feeding
on nectar with the aid of their long
thin tongue this behavior closely
mirrors that of hummingbirds which live
a similar high metabolism lifestyle
feeding on flower nectar it might be
surprising that such disparate species
would converge on the same strategy but
there's evidence to support such an
outcome hummingbird hawk moths are
pollinating insects that independently
became so similar to real hummingbirds
that the two are often mixed up and like
all species occupying the hummingbird
niche the draco sep diana performs a
vital role within their local ecosystem
transporting pollen on the long red
filaments that trail from their head as
they move from flower to flower
pollinating plants is one thing but
among the branches of holly trees i find
one unusual specialist has taken their
connection with the foliage to new
extremes
draco ilexis is a species whose wings
and body have evolved to resemble the
leaves of holly trees making them appear
like living plants as strange as this
specimen might seem there's a long
precedent for such camouflage in nature
defensive mimicry is relatively common
in the larger animal kingdom as
mimicking a plant is a good way to get a
carnivore to ignore you as a food source
if a draco ilexis is spotted however
they have one last offense like the
trees they mimic their wings are covered
in tough thorn-like spikes which make
draco alexis more trouble than they're
worth to most predators
within the foliage of fruit trees i
discover another dragon species makes
clever use of plant mimicry the rotund
draco acidium looks like a round fruit
themselves although they may appear
dangerous with their protruding fangs
this dragon's large teeth are only used
to pierce the tough outer peels of the
fruits they feed on for the draco
acidium is a frugivore meaning their
diet consists mainly of raw fruits many
animals engage in frugivorous behavior
and while this may seem like pilfering
many fruit producing plants benefit from
such interaction certain frugivores
actually assist plants by dispersing
their seeds after digesting them a type
of interaction known as mutualism which
side of the fence the draco acidium
falls on is unknown but it's certainly
possible these tiny dragons act as
natural gardeners of the fruit groves
they call home being slow and flightless
draco essidium also relies on these
trees to keep them hidden although as a
last resort they also possess a powerful
acidic bite
yet other dragons use camouflage for a
more sinister purpose
draco muscular possesses one of the most
unusual hunting strategies of any dragon
able to remain absolutely motionless for
hours at a time they hold their wings
over their head and release a pungent
odor to attract potential prey
carnivorous plants like venus flytraps
have a similar strategy using sweet
smelling nectar to lure in unlucky
insects and like a fly trap once the
draco moves kepler's prey is within
reach the dragon clasps their
specialized wings together stunning
their prey before dropping them into the
waiting jaws beneath for this dragon
patience is more than a virtue
yet not all dragons have evolved to
blend in although just a few centimeters
long the vivid coloration of species
like draco favilla mean they can be
easily spotted and that's exactly the
point like the glaring colors of the
poison dart frog the draco favilla's
coloration is aposomatic meaning it
warns predators the species isn't worth
attacking and while the poison dart frog
backs up their aposomatic hue with
poison draco favilla's color warns of
their deadly venom delivered by tiny
sharp fang jaws this dragon's venom is
potent enough to incapacitate creatures
many times larger than themselves i'll
need to watch where i step
and hidden among the blades of grass
some dragons are even smaller
just two centimeters in length draco
coccinos is perhaps the smallest species
of dragon on the planet indeed they are
so small they stretch our understanding
of what a dragon can be yet remarkably
there is some precedent for a reptile
this size
nano chameleons are chameleon subspecies
that might be the smallest reptiles on
earth at roughly the size of a sunflower
seed at sizes like this the world can be
a daunting place to navigate luckily the
draco coccinos possesses two hair-like
antennae packed with highly sensitive
sense receptors that help them detect
potential threats over long distances
and so this insect-sized dragon does
quite well for themselves within their
unusual niche
in other regions some dragons grow
larger around the curve of a woodland
stream i happen upon a scarcely seen
specimen a draco called daute glistens
in the afternoon sun body poised for a
quick dive into the water the caudate is
an amphibious hunter with webbed toes
and a rudder-like tail the unusually
long and narrow snout of this dragon
contains numerous recurved teeth for
latching on to fish
occupying a niche similar to storks or
herons the draco caudate are natural
fishermen they are also experts at
stealthy movement with their silent
nature making them difficult to track
i'm lucky to be able to observe one
upon the rocky coast some dragons have
become even more specialized aquatic
lifeforms perched on a rock in the
afternoon sun is the bizarre crimson
kimuk possessing a lobster-like tail
fluke for paddling under the frothy
waves this organism fills a niche one
might not expect a dragon to occupy the
crimson kimmu hunts in shallow coastal
waters feeding on mollusks and small
fish behaving like seals or sea lions
they spend a good amount of time out of
the water surveying their territory or
just lazing about upon the rocks
on the front of their snouts they
possess curious tentacular appendages
that further separate their appearance
from the dragons of fairy tales how such
a feature first evolved is a biological
mystery i wonder if i'll find other
species with a similar adaptation
below the surface of the freezing waters
some specimen have given up on land
almost entirely the north nofire are
sleek agile aquatic hunters using their
powerful wings and broad tail for
propulsion their soft downy feathers
help keep them warm in the cold currents
feathers on an aquatic animal might seem
strange but penguins possess feathers
that are shorter and stiffer than those
of most birds keeping them streamlined
in the water we can guess that the no
fear have taken a page from the
penguin's book when it comes to their
feather structure like penguins the
north nofwere are ungainly when not in
the water only able to waddle about in
their elements however these
torpedo-like swimmers are something to
behold
further up the coast seabirds flap above
the crashing waves
and hidden among the flock fearless
surrender storms dive close to the
raging tide these exceptionally rare
dragons can be seen flying high even in
the stormiest weather with such apparent
boldness it would be easy to
sentimentalize these dragons as
courageous yet like seagulls cerano
storms are perhaps closer to pests than
they are to adventurers and spend much
of their time scavenging the picnic
leftovers of tourists while valiantly
stealing discarded food serene storms
often release a call that has been
described as a chuckling sound
considering their surprisingly
intelligent nature it is tempting to
think that these little nuisances are
laughing at us
heading inland i notice that high above
the treetops a flock soars through the
open skies
the pale blue draco ariel lingi are at
first difficult to spot against the
afternoon sky but their graceful curved
wings and v-shaped tail give them an
unmistakable silhouette these graceful
creatures are aerial acrobats spending
much of their time above the canopy but
are able to swoop among the branches in
pursuit of insects certain woodland
raptors are able to perform similar
feats of agility pursuing prey at top
speeds through dense forests without
hitting trees but the draco ariel lingi
can best display their swiftness in the
open air where great flocks such as this
one bank and dive for no reason beyond
their personal enjoyment
soon the night will come to the forest
in the fading light i find hidden among
the trunks a primeval dragon that is
endured into the modern day draco
borealis are a species with a downright
prehistoric appearance resembling
pterosaurs more than any other dragons
i've encountered perhaps the most
distinguishing feature of this species
is their colorful throat pouch iguanas
have similar structures under their
necks that help with thermoregulation
yet the pouch of draco borealis has a
far stranger function an air reserve
this dragon occasionally dives into
lakes to catch fish and uses their
bizarre pouch to extend their lung
capacity the extremes of dragon survival
strategies cannot be underestimated
with the sun about to set on the far
side of the valley i come across a
particularly old region of the woodland
here a heavily built brute with long
curved horns patrols the rotting
branches this is draco baparousas and
they have come here for a meal but it's
not the sort of meal one might expect of
such a beast
dracobabarusis is an insectivore with
their diet composed primarily of ants
and termites they use their highly
specialized head to dig through rotten
bark and leaf litter in search of their
crawling food their top horns also serve
as defensive structures that help draco
barbarus maintain exclusive rights to
their side of the rotting logs with the
sun now almost gone i'll leave
dracobaprusis to their supper
in time dusk falls upon the forest in
the low light i find even more alien
looking dragon species become active
lighting up the dark are the glowing
eyes and tails of draco lampyridae the
function of this natural bioluminescence
isn't immediately apparent but we can
find some potential clues in the natural
world the biochemical glow of fireflies
is thought to serve a number of
functions from scaring off predators to
attracting mates and since these draco
lampyridae are in a pair i wonder if the
glow they give off is perhaps a method
of communication if this is indeed the
case i don't want to interrupt what
seems to be a private conversation
amongst the ancient and decaying trees
of the darkest most inaccessible depths
of the forest a poorly understood
creature is lurking draco johanssi is
scarcely recognizable as a dragon at a
glance possessing a mass of highly
dexterous tentacles surrounding their
mouth while i've spotted other species
with similar appendages draco johansi
takes this adaptation to a new level
like the snout of a star-nosed mole
these appendages help the species
navigate their environment through
tactile input as the draco johansi are
partially sightless yet unlike the star
nose mole this dragon also uses their
appendages to ensnare prey and while
details of diet and behavior remain
largely unknown signs of aggression tell
me to keep my distance
in the dark woods i've seen dreamlike
specimens and beasts that seem to have
wandered from a nightmare yet the last
dragon i encounter is both at once draco
ignis ferendi is an enigmatic omnivore
with a striking appearance they appear
to be bioluminescent with a glowing
green liquid dripping from their teeth
yet draco ignis ferendi's light is
actually borrowed from their primary
food source
glowworms these tiny larva give off a
subtle green glimmer and when mixed with
draco ignis ferendi saliva the glimmer
becomes a hypnotic light in the dark
forest like most species i've glimpsed
today draco ignis ferendi doesn't fit
the traditional myth of the dragon yet
they are undoubtedly a mesmerizing
lifeform
the dragons we've seen today may be
smaller than those of myth and legend
but thanks to their incredible survival
strategies they are no less majestic and
there's so many more species and
biological details to discover in the
incredible volumes of andy frazier there
are even rumors of older dragons that
blend into the moss and stone and that
grow to colossal sizes which the author
will explore in a new book out later
this summer if you find these creatures
as fascinating as i do please follow and
support the artist using the links below
and consider checking out these books
for yourself
and as always thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support and like subscribe and hit
the notification icon to stay up to date
on all things curious
see you in the next video
you